personne n'y échappe la désinformation
n'a pas de frontières mais les
informations trompeuses ont plusieurs
visages pour y voir clair
bouchra vous présente les nuances
possibles dans l'univers de la
désinformation
si vous voyez une histoire inventée de
toutes pièces c'est une force nouvelle
mais si elle est vraie mais qu'elle est
prise hors contexte ou encore qu'elle
est vraie mais quelle date d'il ya
plusieurs années ça c'est la différence
entre la désinformation lama
l'information et la mésinformation la
désinformation c'est quand quelqu'un
veut intentionnellement et d'ouvrir les
gens en erreur et ça peut prendre
plusieurs formes
par exemple ça peut être d'inventer une
histoire de a à z
ou encore faire un montage photo d'une
situation qui n'est jamais arrivé ça
peut aussi être de créer une citation et
de l'attribuer à une personnalité
publique
la malle informations c'est quand lee un
fond de vérité mais que l'histoire est
détournée par exemple si on prend un
vrai discours qu'on sort une phrase de
son contexte pour lui faire dire autre
chose tu as tout bonnement it seems to
put in un petit vote pleurnicher sur
comment son enfance étaient détruits
mettez vous à la place d'un enfant à
gaza ou e-mail ou ailleurs et qui
doivent pourtant quand on écoute toute
la séquence
on voit bien que greta tony berg et n'a
jamais osé se comparer à ses enfants
ute ngono de leurs créances ça peut
aussi être de prendre une photo
authentique mais lui faire raconter une
autre histoire
par exemple ici des étudiants chiliens
ont détruit un crucifix pendant une
manifestation
mais certaines personnes ont dit que
c'étaient plutôt des réfugiés musulmans
en suède et la mésinformation séquence
est une histoire qui est vrai mais qui
s'est produite dans un autre pays ou
encore il y a très longtemps
le problème c'est quand les gens pensent
que l'histoire s'est produite ici et
maintenant
par exemple vous voyez un article qui
annonce qu'un attentat a eu lieu dans
votre ville
mais quand vous cliquez dessus vous
voyez que l'article date d'il ya cinq
ans donc en résumé la désinformation
c'est une information qui est
intentionnellement fausse lama
l'information c'est une information qui
est vrai mais qui est sorti de son
contexte et la mésinformation c'est une
information qui est vrai mais qui n'est
pas d'actualité ici en ce moment
ces trois concepts une montre que la
mauvaise information en et imsa peut
prendre plusieurs formes et que ce qu'on
voit sur internet finalement ce n'est
pas toujours noir ou blanc